Hi everyone, I'm Brian Krueger with CollegeGrad.com and this is the Job Search Minute.
Here's another tough interview question.
Tell me about yourself.
It seems like an easy question.
It's open-ended.
I can talk about whatever I want from the birth canal forward, right?
Wrong, what the hiring manager really wants is a quick two - to - three - minute snapshot...
...of who you are and why you're the best candidate for this position.
So as you answer this question, talk about what you've been doing to prepare yourself...
...to be the very best candidate for the position.
Use an example or two to back it up.
Then ask if they would like more details.
If they do, keep giving them example after example of your background and experience.
Always point back to an example when you have the opportunity.
Tell me about yourself does not mean tell me everything.
Just tell me about what makes you the best.
This has been the job search minute.
For more career information please visit CollegeGrad.com.